こんばんは
ユーチューバー偽物対策本部隊長「はじめしゃちょー」です。
Facebook
Twitter
YouTuber アカウント
世の中には様々なSNS(ソーシャル・ネットワーク・サービス)があるが
まあそこそこ影響力のある人間には
偽物のアカウントというものができてくる　うん
私もいままで、いくつかの偽物アカウントを「ブットバシテ!!」きたからな
今回は新たな手口の偽物アカウントがでてきた
そう…
わたくし、はじめしゃちょー
すでにもう付いています
公式マークが
このマークがあったらこの人が本物かどうかって分かるので
僕は、もう偽物がどれだけでても
このアカウントさえ信じていれば、誰もひっかかからないという
無敵状態でございます　　　が
残念ながら
まぁ、前回もやったんですけども、前回は僕の弟の偽物のアカウントがでてきて
今回！
ふっ
まぁ、さすがですよ
今回はこちらでございます
これは実際に、僕が持ってる
中学校の卒業アルバムなんですけど
前髪切り過ぎちゃって、なんか
ここだけ、はげちゃって
ここだけ、ちょうどはげちゃって
それが、嫌でなんとかしようと思って
マジックで黒塗りしたら
どうしようもないことになっちゃって
すごい悲しくなった卒業アルバムの
写真です
こんなアイコンで「誰だ！」と思ったら
はじめしゃちょーの母でございます
今回のターゲットは、僕のお母さんの偽物アカウント
『はじめしゃちょーの母です』
『いつもはじめがお世話になっております』
『フォローお願いします』
『偽物かどうかはあなたが見極めて下さい』
『場所、はじめからみて実家』
富山
え、めっちゃいるやんフォロワー
めっちゃフォロワーいるやん
2000人超えてるし
ヘッダーもちょっとよくわかんないスよねなんだろうな…
これ俺じゃないからね
俺…ちょ…これ知らないからね
僕のマミーっぽい感じにしようと思って
子供のころのはじめということを想定して
こういうヘッダーにしたのでしょう
私の読みはマチガイナイッ
すっげーツイートしてんな
Twitterでは元と呼べばいいのか…
はじめと呼べばいいのか…(like0)
元、血圧あげすぎちゃダメよー(like0)
今日のお昼は肉じゃがよー(like2)
はやく運動したい（しろ）
ポケモンGOたのしー（画像参照）
はじめしゃちょーの母が9時をお知ら”れ”します
完全にばかにしてるな
ちょっとなんか、何とも言えない
でも僕の母ちゃんが呟きそうな内容なんですよ
これ、実際
皆さんも分かってると思うんですけど、
この人は偽物です
というわけで、今回はこのはじめしゃちょーの母が果たしてどんな人物なのかを調査していこうと思います。
で、一応ですね、事前にDMでちょいちょいやり取りはしてまして
返信遅れてごめんねはじめ
ツイッター始めました。はじめだけに
ねえ、ツイート出来るのに返信できないの？
私を愛してないの？
挑発なの？それとも長髪なの？
これでなんか、
DMのやり取りを動画にしたかったから、「DMいつかたくさんできる日ある？お母ちゃん」っつって
ちゃんと「悪いようにはしないよ」と
ここで時間を検討してくれました
でですね、今日の夜にしようっつって連絡して、ママはどうやら午後8時から12時が暇らしくて　、
というわけで、今からこの偽物とちょっと会話してみます。
はい、というわけで返事が返ってきました。
さっそく見てみましょう
あーママよー
あ！ままぁー！！！こんばんわ！！！
ま、手始めにまず挨拶と行きましょう
まあ基本は挨拶なんでまずは「こんばんわ」という言葉をちゃんと返せるかどうかで人間性を調べていきます。
あー返ってきた。こんばんわ
本当...
汚ねえな。これ本当にオイラが本当に信じてるかどうか感を出してみましょう
えっ母さんえっまじもん！？...おっ返してますね
そ、そうよ、、
まじか
なかなか癖のあるタイプだな
ツイッター始めました
こっからどう攻めいるかですな
いきなりもう斬ってしまいます。今回は
死ね...じゃねいわ
偽物だな！今回はいきなり攻めいります、もう
これでみとめるかどうかで相手がどんなやつか・・・
あなた
母親に向かって
貴様（笑）
これは俺が悪い(笑)
すげーしっかりしてるな
よしよし　くっそ慰めてきやがったな
いやーますます気になりますどんな奴かが
じゃあわたしが母親なのを証明してあげますわよ
うわすげー証明できるらしいです母親ってのを
なんでも質問しなさい
オーすごい
なるほどそうゆう作戦か
誕生日聞いたらこんなのもうワンパンでしょ
フッ
え？
ほらもうこれでいきなりつまっちゃうじゃん
えっと　春ごろか。違います
確か僕の母ちゃんは9月ぐらいだった気がする。あ、そうだったわね
冬でもないわ
完全に...完全に...間違ってやがるこいつ
ママ最近物忘れが激しいのよ
いいまとめ、、、、かただな
てめぇ偽物だな！
もうこのさいなんで、いろいろ聞いてみましょう
家の中で昔、僕がやったことの中で一番悪かったことはなんだったでしょうか？っていう
あー
なつかしいわねぇ
スゲエ母ちゃんズラだな
さぁこれはなかなかむずかしいっしょ
家の中でウーパールーパー勝手に飼ってたことねぇ
飼ってないですよ、、残念！
正解は
家の中で火遊びしてて家ごとまじで燃えそうになったことでした！
残念だったな
父ちゃんに殺されかけたけどな
ほらもう焦って字の変換もおかしくなっちゃっているじゃん
さあ焦っているな貴様そろそろ正体をあらわしなさい
はじめちゃーん
てめぇ！
ゴルァ
怖いわよぅ
オレオレ詐欺じゃねーわ
く、こいつバカにしやがって
そろそろ正直になりなさい
あなたは男？女？ひとまず男か女かを知りましょう
この質問にどう答えるかで変わっていきますよ今後が
ママなんだから絶対におん…
おんた！？今回のプレイヤーはなかなかしぶといな
ちょいちょいとみっくさん挟むななんだろうな
ここでちょっと本気で一回頼み込んでみます
偽物よ。そろそろ正直に話してくれないか
そんなに言われたら悲しくなるじゃないのよ
頼む。この通りだ
よし。これで俺の母ちゃんは落ちる
おぉ
きたぞ
やっぱり写真効果は強かったぞ
一発で性別を教えてくれるらしい
しょうがないわね　性別だけなら教えてあげるわ
男じゃねぇか!!